a state of emergency in minneapolis
and a state of disbelief after another
shooting of a black man by police
at such a tense time for this city
tear gas deployed on protesters after a
routine traffic stop
became another death
police body cam footage of the arrest
was released hours later
in an unfathomable turn of events a 20
year old black man
shot by an officer they say by accident
[Music]
they can be heard screaming as the
officer appears to realize
they've fired their handgun instead of
their taser
father of one dante wright died after
being shot by a single bullet
the governor of minnesota drawing
comparisons to the death of george floyd
last year
our time was made clear last may in
minnesota
our time to get one shot at fixing it
was there and in the midst of this trial
that's the world's watching
the situation repeated itself yesterday
so
this is a call to us again to minnesota
and to the rest of the nation
we have the ability to reduce the chance
of this happening
just 10 miles away former officer derek
shovin is on trial for the murder of
george floyd
his younger brother filonus breaking
down in tears in court
as he talks about the impact it's had on
his family
that's my mother she's no longer with us
right now but
that's my oldest brother george
i miss both of them they are
i was married in may 24th i got married
and my brother was killed may 25th
and my mom died on may 30th
it's like a bittersweet month because
i'm supposed to be happy when a mom
comes
and today more tough testimony for
george floyd's family
that his death was preventable had it
not been for the actions of derek
chauvin
he would have survived had he not been
restrained
in the way in which he was i
think he would have survived that day i
think he would have gone home or
wherever he was going to go
had he not been subjected to the prone
and positional restraint that he was the
same could be said
for dante wright who didn't make it home
from a routine traffic stop
igniting protests and unrest in a city
already on edge sally lockwood sky news
minneapolis